Marvel's most powerful superhero has
finally arrived on the big screen
leaving absolutely no doubt that Carol
Danvers will go on to play a vital role
in upcoming MCU storylines and like any
action-packed Marvel fest there were
plenty of references on-screen that were
easy to miss submit all the photon
blasts and space battles from characters
with secret futures - sneaky wardrobe
changes to Easter eggs here are all of
the small details you missed in Captain
Marvel spoilers ahead Oh spoiler alert
one of the film's biggest moments came
when carol danvers finally discovered
her true colors both figuratively and
literally upon deciding to ditch the
Kree and help the scroll refugees Carol
figures she needs a new look to match
your new mission fortunately the Kree
suit makers programmed a Sims wardrobe
module into her handy-dandy wrist
gadgets allowing her to switch up her
suits design right then and there she
flashes through all the colors of the
rainbow before settling on the iconic
blue red and yellow look the fans of the
comics couldn't help but cheer for him
but right before her final colors her
suit rests for a moment on a mild green
and white color scheme that might be
familiar to diehard comics readers in
Captain Marvel's first comics appearance
as Marvel in Marvel superheroes number
12 the Kree hero wears a suit with the
same colors even if it was only on
screen for a few seconds it was a clever
nod to the superheroes origins and more
than a little fitting that it appeared
as a precursor to a current suit design
sharp-eyed audience members might have
noticed a strange discrepancy in the way
the Kree were portrayed most of the Kree
we see on-screen have blue skin Minerva
Atlas Ronan the list goes on there are
only a few exceptions to this that we
see Carol Danvers who obviously is human
to begin with and Yan raagh a true-blue
Kree in every sense but the color so
what gives was it a mistake by the
filmmakers did you'd lost decide not to
fume ke himself for production
[Music]
I feel like a idiot as it turned out
that was deliberate although it's never
mentioned in the film
Captain Marvel number 38 explains that
when the Kree race began the conquest of
space they mated with other species and
created so-called pink skin Kree a
variant of the species that looks
conveniently like Caucasian humans
Marvel also had this trait which is one
of the reasons she was able to stay on
earth as dr. Lawson and worked on her
project for the scrolls without drawing
attention to herself you know because
people in the office tend to notice a
blue person after the third or fourth
day as a film Captain Marvel really
starts gaining momentum when Carol
Danvers crashes through the roof of a
blockbuster on earth it's a good moment
for a laugh especially if you happen to
live through the mid 90s after photon
blasting a cardboard cutout of Arnold
Schwarzenegger in a true lies promo
display Carol wanders down the aisle
marveling at the bizarre store at one
point she fix up a VHS and examines it
then puts it back on the shelf if you
were paying attention you might have
noticed that the video she looks at is
the right stuff a 1983 film about seven
pilots who train to become the first
Americans in space it's a fitting film
for her to pick up since the astronauts
in the right stuff have an arc that
mirrors Carol Danvers own path through
the film first she discovers her past as
an Air Force pilot then flies into space
herself and a modified airforce craft
there was one thread woven throughout
the plot of Captain Marvel that was
never fully explained despite the impact
it's had over the years that was project
Pegasus the joint Air Force and NASA
project headed by dr. Lawson as it turns
out Pegasus isn't a new creation even in
the MCU Marvel Studios has been working
with the idea since at least 2012 before
the Avengers was released Marvel put out
a short pre loot comic entitled Fury's
big week the comic connected elements
from Captain America the First Avenger
the Incredible Hulk and Iron Man in
preparation for the big cinematic team
up and it introduced project Pegasus
just after that the project made its
big-screen debut
if you go back and watch The Avengers
closely you can see that the opening
scene when Loki steals the tesseract
goes down at the Pegasus facility of
course this isn't entirely
first appearance for project Pegasus
it's actually been around in the comics
for quite a while
nominally a research center for powerful
energy sources
the facility is also served as a
makeshift prison for supervillains over
the years notably project Pegasus was
once the workplace of Wendell Vaughan
who became the superhero quasar and
later took the mantle of protector of
the universe after Captain Marvel died
yeah that's as important as it sounds in
one scene toward the end of the film
young Nick Fury is contemplating the
events of the past few days and working
out a new idea to find superheroes to
protect the earth the reasons that since
they just had a run end with a whole
bunch of aliens there have to be more
super-powered folk out there he
initially has the name the protector
initiative on his computer screen before
he notices Carol Danvers Air Force
callsign Avenger and changes it to the
name we've all come to love over the
past decade or so there was an idea
stark knows this called the Avengers
initiative it's the kind of thing that
works as a callback to past films and
future events but there's actually a
second layer to this scene there are
actually several times that a version of
Captain Marvel has also been designated
protector one of them is another Kree
warrior noh-varr who spends some time
with the name Captain Marvel while
working with the Dark Avengers
eventually though no var leaves the team
and has given a new name by the Supreme
intelligence protector more importantly
in one of Marvel's earlier story arcs
he's transported to the realm of a being
called iya who's a giant floating tree
eyeball thing this eon is also
incredibly powerful and he leads Captain
Marvel on a cosmic journey that teaches
him how to harness all power by the end
of this transformation Eon gives him a
new title protector of the universe
after that Marvel uses his powers to
help stop none other than fan OHS from
destroying the universe considering how
close Avengers in-game is to the release
of Captain Marvel it makes you wonder if
dimension is a little more than just a
throwaway joke we're all expecting to
see Captain Marvel go head-to-head
against the math type if there's one
character who stole the show in Captain
Marvel it was definitely goose the
unassuming tabby who tagged the law
with Danvers and Fury in their
adventures who do fury was such a cat of
course there's a lot more to this cat
that meets the eye first starters the
name is clearly a subtle nod to Top Gun
in which Anthony Edwards character
codenamed goose is an Air Force pilot
aside from that though there's also the
small detail of the purple people eating
tentacles that sprout out of gooses
mouth and the fact that goose isn't even
a cat at all he is a flirt in an alien
species that just happens to look like a
cat Fleur khun's first appeared to
Marvel Comics readers in 2014 in the
pages of Captain Marvel when it turned
out that Danvers cat Chewie was secretly
one of the tentacle beasts in disguise
after being attacked by rocket racoon
who saw Chewie for the Fleur Kimmy was
she we finally unleashed the beast and
saved Rockets life ah kid Fleur Caen
young actress Akira Akbar turned in a
fine performance as Monica Rambeau the
eleven-year-old daughter of Carol's
friend and fellow pilot Maria Rambo
Monica was there during some of the
film's most hard-hitting moments helping
carol danvers rediscover her past and
giving the discovery that extra
emotional edge she even helped Carol
pick the right colors for her new suits
but one particular line of dialogue
carried more significance than it may
have seemed too near the end of the
movie Monica asks if she'll eventually
go into space too that leads to the
seemingly casual line only if you learn
to glow like your auntie but here's the
thing
Monica does learn to glow like her
auntie her name has changed over the
years but fans may know her best is
Photon a hero with the ability to
harness electromagnetic forces in her
current incarnation Monica Rambeau goes
by the name spectrum and there was even
a time when she flew under the Captain
Marvel mantle in fact when Monica's
character debuted a 1982 issue of the
Amazing Spiderman
she was billed as the all-new
all-different all terrific Captain
Marvel another nod to Monica's comic
book counterpart can be seen on the side
of Maria's fighter which has the stencil
Maria Foton Rambo does this foreshadow
big things in the future for little
Monica maybe maybe not either way it's
an exciting detail from the comics
played by Jim
Minerva is one of the star force members
who joins Danvers in the battle on tour
feh
early in the film Minerva has a fairly
respectable comics presence and she's
been involved in some seriously twisted
plot
she's as Kree as they come fiercely
loyal to arrays and often willing to go
to extreme lengths for the betterment of
the Kree civilization in one
particularly heinous plan during the
Civil War event Minerva tried to Elise a
biological weapon in California that
would have turned people into mutated
monsters Captain Marvel was able to stop
her even though Minerva turned into a
giant mutation herself during the fight
in another instance she was part of the
supreme intelligence as planned to
destroy 90% of the Kree population to
make the remaining 10% stronger than
ever
yeah that's not the kind of person you
really want on your team or even on your
species if we're being honest like
Minerva Atlas has had his share of
comics page done although to a lesser
extent his biggest contribution to the
film was getting mimicked by a Skrull
but there's more to this blue-faced
warrior than meets the eye in addition
to his involvement in operation galactic
storm massive crossover event that put
earth in the middle of a war being
fought by the Kree and Shiar Atlas has
also shown up as the villainous titanium
man in the Infinity heist miniseries ad
less becomes titanium man to join the
crew of villains robbing stark tower
there he unmasks himself and reveals
that the Kree were behind the heist the
whole time causing the rest of the bad
guys to turn against him and he gets
killed in the melee oh well guess not
everyone can be a criminal genius back
when Jude Law was announced to be part
of the Captain Marvel cast most of the
internet speculated he would play the
role of marvel they were wrong of course
his real role is that of Yann Rock it
turns out that Marvel had a good reason
to keep law's role of secret see yon rug
is a well-known enemy of Marvel's so
fans might have seen a big twist in
Captain Marvel coming a mile away in the
film Carol Danvers eventually discovers
that Yann rod killed marvel at the crash
site of her experimental plane then
abducted Danvers and took her back to
Halle when she absorbed the Power Core
he'd been after that pretty much
characterizes the character in the
comics one detail fans may not have
thought about this whole reveal is that
it mirror
a similar moment in the comics though
with a much different outcome in 1969 s
Captain Marvel number 18 Marvel faces
off against the yan rock who is
kidnapped an earth woman named that's
right
Harold Danvers and kept her prisoner
near a powerful cream machine called the
psyche magnetron after Marvel and Yan
Raj the psyche magnetron explodes and
seemingly kills Yan Raj while
simultaneously knocking some super
powers into Danvers in both the comics
and cinematic universes then Yan rock is
directly responsible for Danvers gaining
her powers maybe he's not such a bad guy
after all well okay maybe he is one
member of the star force team is much
more recognizable than the owners core
at the pursue burr played by Djimon
Hounsou is no stranger to the MCU he
first appeared on screen in the opening
moments of guardians of galaxy where you
may remember he tried to take the power
stone from star-lord who star-lord man
legendary outlaw guys move he showed up
again on the Battle of Zander and proved
to be a formidable opponent at least
until Drax ripped off part of his head
with Captain Marvel we get to see a
younger Korath in his prime still
kicking butt and still well alive and
kicking in general of all the star force
members Korath is certainly one of the
most powerful in the comics he's a
geneticist and took to modifying his own
body with all kinds of cybernetic sci-fi
implants giving him super strength and
speed casual fans may not know that he's
gone up against the likes of Captain
America Scarlet Witch and Adam warlock
those are big foes but to be fair he
usually does come out on the losing side
another no doubt familiar face and
Captain Marvel is that of Ronan the
accuser whose name dropped early in the
film before making his first big
appearance during the climax you know
he's the blue guy with a big hammer fun
fact that hammer is also known as the
universal weapon and grants him such
abilities as transmutation matter and
interstellar transportation why don't we
ever see any of those abilities in the
film's probably for the same reason
Ronan's importance is downplayed in
general fortunately Captain Marvel did
offer a hand of his full power within
the Kree Empire by positioning him at
the head of a battleship that goes to
earth in the comics
he's one of the most well known Kree
warriors in a civilization that spans
multiple star systems of course if we're
going to talk about comics characters
whose roles were reduced by film we have
to mention Marvel in Captain Marvel
Annette Bening famous for roles and
films like American Beauty portrayed the
Kree soldier who was moonlighting as dr.
Lawson on earth she played an important
role in the plot but of course there's
no mention that Marvel is well the
original Captain Marvel with the
standalone series launched in 1968
Marvel's version of Captain Marvel
contained all the elements of the Marvel
we saw and screamed just with
superpowers
he's a Kree warrior who comes to earth
and disguises himself as dr. Lawson then
decides to protect humanity instead of
battling them in the film it's the
Skrulls Marvel tries to protect but it's
the same idea
unfortunately the hero wasn't very
popular at the time and Stanley came up
with the idea to deal with him in the
least comic-book friendly way imaginable
in the death of Captain Marvel graphic
novel
Captain Marvel gets cancer and dies and
at the end of it all Thanos visits him
and takes him on a hallucinogenic
journey to fight all his old foes again
it's weird and strangely heartbreaking
as jaan raghav
the supreme intelligence appears to be
something different to everyone
something important from their lives
that's good news for film goers because
for years we've just been seeing the
Supreme intelligence as a fat green head
floating in a jar so let's talk about
this supreme intelligence creature in
the film we got the idea it was sort of
a therapist for confused Kree and
sometimes a prison for people who
betrayed the crew the truth is it is
kind of those things in the comics
despite being the Kree leader it never
seems to have the best in mind for its
people it Avengers number 347 for
example the supreme intelligence
detonated a Nega bomb and almost
completely wiped out the Kree woops
Captain Marvel featured a major cameo
that most likely delighted hardcore
comics fans this one came in the train
station when Carol Danvers is wandering
around lost and still wearing her Kree
uniform while multiple people passerby
on the platform one lady who walks fast
is none other than writer Kelly Sudha
Khan
Taconic began writing captain marvel in
2012 leading to a version of the
character which heavily inspired the
film incarnation
if you mr. cameo in the film you
probably weren't alone but it's
definitely one of those small details
you need to keep an eye out for during
any future re watches finally it was a
bittersweet moment to see Stan Lee in
his final Marvel cameo after his decades
of contributions to the comic-book
industry
Captain Marvel fittingly paid tribute in
its opening moments switching out the
typical Marvel Studios intro with one
dedicated to the late great leaf Carol
Danvers herself gave the man the nod of
respect during his cameo on the train
that in itself was a fine detail but the
film went even deeper with cameo since
Captain Marvel is set during the 90s Lee
appears as himself reading the script
for Mallrats and trying to remember his
lines for those who don't remember 1995
small rats marked one of Stan Lee's
first film cameos of course it's much
more than a cameo with Stan Lee giving
chase Lee's character a piece of stage
dating advice through the lens of comic
books
trust me true believer well good talking
to you keep up all the good work you
keep reading them I'll keep writing them
it has some pretty amazing layers for a
cameo and marks the perfect send-off
looping back around full circle to the
very beginnings of Stan Lee's film
appearances rest in peace true believer
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero films are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]